I am a hipster, I am an honest-to-god,
dyed-in-the-wool EDH hipster. I like to
play weird, unusual decks that do weird, unusual
things with weird, unusual cards. The idea that
I might be playing a deck that does something
nobody has done before is extremely cool to me,
and that specific task is something that is far
more possible to do in EDH than in just about any
other format. The format has a card selection
that’s almost as wide as Vintage’s, it has
thousands of different options for commanders, and
the fact that it doesn’t have a single set power
level means that no deck is fully squeezed out
as long as you’re willing to shop around for an
appropriate table to play at. The level of freedom
that the format offers to deck builders can be
genuinely overwhelming for the people who aren’t
used to that, but for the most dedicated brewers
of the world it’s basically one big playground of
possibilities. Do you have a funky vision you want
to realize? EDH can absolutely accommodate that. I
do firmly believe all that about the format, and I
have long had the goal of pushing the envelope
on how weird and niche casual EDH can get,
but for the past couple months I’ve also had a
nagging thought. Is the version of the EDH format
I’m describing actually a good one? One that leads
the most people to have the most fun? Is having a
weird-off with the table where everybody tries to
do the most performatively unusual things actually
a good way to play Magic? Might it even be more
ethical, better to one’s fellow Magic players,
to play a deck that’s simpler or does
something more common? So in this video,
I’m going to explore that nagging doubt, but
first I need to lay out a bit of context.
The period between 2002 and 2011 saw the EDH
format grow from a scarcely-known novelty to
a format Wizards of the Coast was willing
to print cards specifically for. A big
step in this process was its adoption as a
casual pickup format among Pro Tour judges,
with the late Sheldon Menery effectively
serving as the format’s guide and foremost
advocate during this period and beyond. The
appeal here is clear—it was a more casual way
of playing that could manifest at events once
the more cutthroat 1v1 matches of the day had
been concluded. Even after the first precons were
released, this culture of pickup games remained
strong across the format. Anecdotally, I played
a decent amount of commander during downtime
at local limited and standard events in 2014 and
2015, and it just made sense as a format to play
when people were looking for a bit of variety.
In his article for Polygon a few years back,
Charlie Hall highlighted some of the appeals—if
a handful of people want to play a game of Magic,
rather than figuring out an appropriate format to
play or double checking that a couple casual decks
are built under similar ethos, commander offers an
elegant, one-size-fits-all solution with a broad
card pool and a slim banlist. Though EDH has
since become its own main event in most cases,
played among friend groups and in dedicated
leagues at local game stores, there are visible
indications of the lingering influence of pickup
games in the direction Wizards of the Coast has
taken with the products they market to commander
players. While they used to sell a product called
a “Deckbuilder’s Toolkit” as a way for casual
players to build their first deck on their own
time, these got phased out a few years ago to
be replaced with greater Arena support and more
products for commander, the now-de-facto casual
format of paper magic. Relevant to my point here,
most of these products are preconstructed
commander decks, which are ready-to-play
out of the box—if you’re sitting in a game store
and a few other people start to play commander,
you can walk up to the counter to buy a precon
and some sleeves and you’ll be good to go in
a few minutes, assuming you have a couple
helpful compatriots to help you sleeve up.
Now, at this point, you may be saying “but Alex,
how is this relevant?” Well, let’s take a minute
to think about the pickup EDH experience, where
you sit down at a table and start up a casual EDH
game with three unfamiliar opponents who are
playing largely unfamiliar decks. Put simply,
it can be a little overwhelming sometimes,
and I’m speaking purely from an information
standpoint. With the format being slow and four
player, the board gets gradually clogged with
increasing numbers of assorted permanents of
various stripes, with the purpose of any single
one being potentially unclear. And this is EDH
in the year of our lord 2024, so all of these
have a lot of text, too much text some might
argue. With thousands of commander options,
there’s a good chance of at least one of
these at the table being one you haven’t
played against. Knowledge of how your opponents
plan to win will likely be incomplete at best,
and next-to-nonexistent at worst if nobody
bothered to pose that question to the table.
Pickup EDH can be an absolute information
overload, and this broader problem can be
broken down into two separate sub-problems:
card diversity, and gameplay diversity.
As far as card diversity goes, the EDH format
has tens of thousands of cards available to it,
and a much less restrictive banlist than Legacy
which otherwise shares a similar card pool. Not
only this, but since the format is 100-card
singleton, seeing any singular card in a deck
gives far fewer implications for what the rest of
the deck might contain compared to other formats,
and also results in far more unique cards in
each deck. Multiply this by three to account
for the multiplayer aspect of the format, and
there will be a lot of cards to keep track of
just as a baseline. Traditionally, veterans
of a given format will better be able to
keep up with different things opponents
are playing due to wider card knowledge,
but with Wizards of the Coast increasing the
number of brand new cards they print into the
commander format from the high hundreds
per year to multiple thousand per year,
keeping up even as an experienced EDH player
can be difficult. My friend Hans built a funky
new deck recently, and even as somebody who
basically thinks about EDH as a profession,
there were a surprising number of cards
from this deck that I had no familiarity
with whatsoever. In a game with several decks
containing unfamiliar cards, just processing
these new pieces of cardboard and figuring out
how to play against them in real time can eat
up precious mental energy that could otherwise
go toward planning future turns, politicking,
and performing threat analysis on other cards.
And that’s with a group of experienced players.
The new player experience in EDH is a whole
different beast. While the number of different
nonland cards in opponents’ decks in a 60 card
1v1 format might be somewhere in the 15-20 range,
in EDH that number might be ten times that amount.
Getting a foothold in that environment will be a
difficult and time-consuming process even in
a setting with somewhat consistent decks and
players, and in an environment with rapidly
changing decks and players this is amplified.
I’m not saying it’s impossible—there are
plenty of magic players who have learned
the game through EDH, and I’m sure there are
some who even thrived in this high stimulation,
information-dense environment. There are also
likely plenty of people who learned the format
somewhat more gradually, but who had plenty of fun
throughout the whole process even if they weren’t
keeping up 100% the whole time. I certainly don’t
think it’s worth anyone’s time and energy to push
players away from the commander format; it
has very clearly taken hold of casual Magic,
and there are lots of aspects of it that are
likely fun for newer players. What I am saying,
though, is that increasing the card diversity
of decks does meaningfully increase the length
of time it’ll take for a new player to get
a foothold within the format. When I made
my video about cEDH a few months back, I got
a number of interesting comments from people
who prefer competitive EDH specifically because
there are fewer viable cards in the format that
require keeping track of. A few of these were from
people who had jumped straight into cEDH from a 60
card format or a different card game entirely, and
this makes sense on some level—if you’re looking
to play commander seriously and don’t want
to have to bother with learning the thousands
upon thousands of cards that see play in casual
EDH, cEDH is a nice alternative. It may even be,
as a casual EDH player in the comments pondered,
a smoother experience for those wanting to play
commander with strangers, for more reasons
than one. I see this as the most reasonable
response to my main gripe with cEDH—“yes, fewer
cards are viable, and that’s good, actually.”
The issue of the EDH format’s card diversity is
compounded when decks are equally diverse in their
play patterns. The origins of the format were
people throwing together their bulk cards they
couldn’t play in standard and playing them under
the banner of a commander that was vaguely-related
at best, and this likely resulted in unfocused
blobs of midrange being a dominant deck type,
maybe with some funky synergies coming to the fore
here and there. And, as a casual pickup format,
this makes sense—if decks are built more to
produce relaxed games and showcase unusual
cards than to win, the presence of those cards
can take center stage. Like sure, you might have
to refresh yourself on what Freyalise Supplicant
does, but it’s probably not going to rapidly spell
your downfall. However, as decks have gotten more
streamlined and have started trying to accomplish
increasingly specific tasks increasingly quickly,
lacking knowledge of the ins and outs of what your
opponent’s deck is doing starts to become more of
a problem. As you might expect, this effect also
scales with power level up to a certain point.
If you’re playing against unaltered precons,
you can usually at least assume there will be some
sort of synergy-based midrange thing going on,
along with a couple predictable side synergy
packages. If you’re playing against a handful
of mid-power midrange decks, there will likely be
less certainty and more surprises, but you still
can probably get at least a rough idea of what’s
going on without knowing the opposing decks.
However, it’s the power level I’d describe as high
power casual where things start to feel really
weird when playing with strangers. Infinite
combos, locks, and back-breakingly-powerful
value engines get assembled on a whim and with
only relatively subtle hints to indicate their
approach. Whereas in cEDH there is a smaller group
of viable strategies, with off-meta tech being a
spicy exception rather than the rule, high power
casual is packed to the rafters with off-meta,
because there isn’t a meaningful meta beyond some
archetypes being a bit more popular than others.
Now, I do love me some high power casual,
and I can even see a sort of weird allure in
playing it with unfamiliar people and unfamiliar
decks—it’s a zany, explosive form of Magic, where
games are often quick and where there’s a ton of
sleuthing the ins and outs of opposing decks that
happens on the fly. But I’d also wager that this
is where a big dose of frustration comes from in
pickup magic, particularly in games that straddle
the line between mid and high power, and where
players enter with differing expectations. If
everybody is already needing to process the cards
and decks of three different opponents, and they
don’t know the cohesive plan of any one opponent,
let alone three… well, this is an environment
where it’s very easy to slip through a power
play that opponents just aren’t equipped to
challenge. Sure, one could argue “just hold
up removal,” but that misunderstands the nature of
threat assessment. If I know my opponents’ decks,
I can think to myself “okay, I’m 90% sure player
A doesn’t have the pieces to combo off on their
next turn, and player B should be two mana short
of a game-winning spell.” And then decisions can
be made on whether to hold up interaction based
on if I have other useful plays to make that
outweigh the risk. But, if instead of being 85%
sure it’s safe to tap out I have no firm estimate
whatsoever, what exactly am I supposed to do? Hold
up mana every turn? The answer is probably hold up
mana when it’s nice to do so and don’t when it’s
not and maybe do my best to follow context clues,
but then on some level that’s just a random luck
check for whether or not I lose to some bullshit,
right? This effect is unfortunately amplified the
more unique ways of gaining advantage and winning
exist within a game—you can keep track of some
number of cards commonly associated with combos,
but when decks have plans that are weird or
unconventional there will be plenty of things that
will slip through the cracks. In competitive terms
you might call it brewer’s advantage, but in a
casual context it can create dynamics that aren’t
necessarily positive for everybody involved.
With all that in mind, it might make sense that
the experience that gave me my love for weird,
offbeat EDH decks was actually an environment that
had basically none of these problems. From fall
of 2019 to summer of 2021 my playgroup of five
people played about 200 games with a set of ten
budget decks, with each deck seeing an average
of one major rebuild over the course of those
two years. Though several of these decks were
quirky and evocative, and though the card choices
in them got pretty funky, the fact that we were
exclusively playing with these ten guild-divided
decks meant that the plans for each deck and
the cards used within those plans became all
but public knowledge. Multiple players basically
learned the game through this pool, and despite
the diversity within the pool this was an ideal
environment for that—you could learn the game
pieces and what each deck was doing reasonably
easily, and even if you’d forgotten something,
other players at the table were likely vocalizing
relevant information. If you don’t think about it
too hard, you might assume that this trait is
shared by a lot of casual playgroups. And yes,
the best arguments against decks with unusual
cards and unique gameplans do relate to pick
up games with largely unfamiliar opponents, but
plenty of these arguments also apply to games
within dedicated playgroups. For one, players
these days often have a lot of decks—while
the idea of building a second commander deck
was silly to me in 2015, a quick poll in the
Patron channel of my discord server showed
that around 60% of respondents had at least
8 decks. While the average is probably lower
than this, I have to imagine a lot of dedicated
playgroups still feature a hefty number
of unique decks among the various players,
well above the 10 seen at my table a few
years back. In addition, not all playgroups
meet frequently enough to fully keep track of the
ins and outs of each others decks—while my small
playgroup of 20-year olds played several games
a week at the height of pandemic-fueled boredom,
plenty of Magic players are busy adults with
time-consuming jobs, time-consuming children,
an extremely dedicated all-bard D&D campaign,
or some combination of these things. There also
might be a somewhat rotating player group,
with fresh decks being a regular sighting.
Under these sorts of circumstances, much of the
information overload present in pick up EDH will
likely also be present. And, if this is the case,
one could argue that players playing simpler decks
with more commonly seen cards may very well
lead to more fun for everybody at the table.
So, that’s my case for why running funky,
unique decks is not an unquestioned good,
and can in fact amplify one of the
biggest problems with the casual EDH
format—the overwhelming amount of information
it presents players with. And let me clear,
I find this argument extremely interesting,
almost paralyzingly interesting. And yet,
the deckbuilding conclusions that it gestures
at run almost perfectly contradictory to the
hipster tendencies that all but define my
deck building style. So, how do we square
that circle? Well for starters, in all of the
examples I gave of what might constitute a bad
experience as a result of decks being weird
and unusual, there are tons of other factors
that might contribute to the information density
at the table. For example, I emphasize that this
issue is vastly more problematic in settings with
strangers and unknown decks, but the unknowability
of decks isn’t a set in stone thing. You and your
opponents can tell each other what your decks do,
and you can go into whatever amount of detail
suits the decks present and suits the game you
want to play. Whenever I play with new people
at my local game store I’ll generally give
some explanation of the deck I’m playing while I’m
shuffling up, and I’ll often ask for the same from
my opponents. Even when it’s trading relatively
simple explanations, this act can allow players to
go into games with a sense of groundedness, having
at least some idea of what they’re getting into.
There are also additional actions during games
that can further elucidate what’s happening
within a game, and a relatively basic one I’ve
seen pretty often is verbally differentiating
commonly-game-ending spells from other spells.
For example, saying “I play a Llanowar Elves”
versus “I attempt to cast Scapeshift.” I like this
a lot because it’s not even an insult to the game
knowledge of your opponents—on the contrary,
you’re treating them like seasoned veterans of
playing against your deck who would know that
you resolving Scapeshift is a problem, or at
least something worth paying full attention to.
I’ll even sometimes draw attention to important
information I’ve revealed—when I’m playing
my Francisco Malcolm deck against people who
haven’t played against it much before, if I reveal
Shred Memory off of an explore on turn 4, I might
say something like “I’ll keep Shred Memory on top,
there’s a particular two mana card I might want to
transmute for sometime soon,” as a gentle reminder
of what my deck is trying to do. Now, that’s the
only deck I give that amount of information for
since it’s a deceptively fast combo deck that’s
generally on the more powerful end of my store’s
high-power casual pods, but that’s just an example
of how giving extra information can reduce
whiplash and lead to a better play experience.
Another method I’ve commonly seen is keeping
revealed cards revealed longer than is required,
most often putting a revealed card into
hand face up for a turn or two or leaving
the revealed top card of a library face-up until
it’s drawn. This likewise removes a bit of mental
strain from opponents by not requiring them to
immediately commit revealed cards to memory.
Some of this might seem a bit obvious, but I
feel the need to say it explicitly because I
got a lot of confusing comments on my
commander-as-a-combo-piece video from
players who seem to think that deception is a
key feature of the EDH format. Not bluffing,
like purposefully concealing key details about
the cards contained within one’s deck for purposes
of pulling off a “gotcha” win. This is
obviously fine in competitive formats,
since there is a meta/countermeta dynamic at play,
and I imagine some people enjoy playing this way
in casual EDH as well. However, to reiterate an
earlier point, decks being unknown makes threat
assessment vastly more difficult, and as a result
injects a lot of extra luck into games, and I
certainly don’t find that enjoyable personally.
I also find the idea of trying to sneak through
an explosive win against a table who’s not
prepared for or looking for that kind of EDH
to be a little distasteful, but that’s subjective
territory and I can’t claim to know the desires
of any specific EDH table, so I won’t throw
any extra words at that particular subject.
Beyond the gameplay methods for getting around
this information overload, there can also be
attributes of the decks at the table that
affect the degree of information present.
Is this the part where I find yet another excuse
to tell you to play more removal? Well, kind of,
but not exactly. The other big thing that made
the $25 deck pool I used to play with so good for
avoiding information overload was that the decks
were interaction dense, as well as low-slung and
grindy to be able to handle the aforementioned
interaction. The fact that the pool began with
two boardwipe-dense control decks meant that
every midrange deck was designed with the goal
of not overcommitting to the board, which means
fewer nonland permanents on board and less of
the escalation-type cards that typically pump
mid-sized midrange boards up to being alarming
masses of assorted permanents in a lot of casual
EDH games. I should be clear—this worked well
because these 10 decks formed a little meta,
and your mileage may vary in multiple regards
if you try to emulate any of this in a pod of
more conventionally-built EDH decks. However,
it does gesture at a vision for EDH that’s
much more approachable than a lot of what
I see at local game stores, and while it’s not
necessarily a vision that can or should be copied,
it gives a useful benchmark to reference
for what EDH can look like. When removal
is absent and everybody is just allowed to
do their deck’s snowbally midrange thing,
boardstates often end up utterly caked in the
extra noise of various synergy permanents and
utility creatures and tokens, and I think
it’s always worth asking the question of if
that’s a worthwhile way to play, and if there
are ways to avoid that sort of boardstate.
Beyond my practical recommendations, I also
think it’s worth considering what EDH represents.
Because you may have noticed that the potential
version of EDH I gestured at earlier in the video,
one where decks operate within a narrower set
of potential gameplans with a narrower range of
cards, is one that more closely resembles 60 card
formats. Chasing this vision for the format might
have its benefits in some ways, but at what cost?
There are so many things that can only be done in
EDH, and so many cards that aren’t really viable,
or even legal, in most other formats. I think it’s
worth considering the case that EDH can be an
overwhelming format at times, and I think it’s
also worth considering how to mitigate those
problems. It might even be worthwhile for newer
players to try and sprinkle some variety into
their MTG diet—I’m of the opinion that almost
all Magic players can benefit from playing
limited, and cube can give a nice way to play
limited without feeling like you’re wasting your
money on packs that you haven’t yet developed the
skill to fully utilize. But no, reducing the
variety of the format isn’t the solution, and
it isn’t worth it. The creation of the original
Elder Dragon Highlander format is often credited
to Adam Staley, and Staley conceptualized the
format as a way to inject variety and creativity
into a game whose constructive formats were
already rigid and meta-driven even in the first
few years of the game. Singleton meant
being forced to play underutilized cards,
a wide card pool meant decks could be constructed
with basically any old cards sitting around,
and a higher life total meant more space for
creative but slower strategies that would
likely get squeezed out by faster decks in a 20
health format. An Elder Dragon at the head of
things gave an undeniable symbolic core to decks.
A format as large as EDH can’t be solely governed
by the vision of one man 30 years ago, but you
have to admit—he was kind of onto something.